this stuff is crazy now you've been
doing first of all it's great to have
you back on here I missed you but yeah
you've been interviewing lots of people
from all over the world Spain Italy
Greece New York doing Skype chats with
all kinds of people that have been
affected by this coronavirus what it so
what have you learned what's the biggest
thing you've been learning from all
these people from talking to everyone
one was two to four weeks ago
I started to get emails from people in
Spain and Italy asking me to want people
in the UK and the USA what was coming so
I started to read those emails out on
camera and then in the comments there
was this horrible backlash people saying
I'm trying to cause a panic the flu is
more dangerous than this only all people
are dying in Italy it's not coming to
the u.s. it's not coming to the UK so
that's all right rather than just read
these letters out
I shall interview people in these
hotspots maybe that would be more
impactful so I started to interview
people in the hotspots and the things
that they were saying were happening you
know all people need in intensive care
unit beds being turned away doctors
deciding who lives and dies makeshift
beds been made in tents and bodies just
been laid down in corridors his blankets
thrown over them people who are still
alive but couldn't get any intensive
care units one of the most recent videos
dozens of all people just found dead in
a home in Spain so having the actual
video testimonies of these people
started to wake people up in this
country our government was saying well
we aren't really God policy of lockdown
we're just gonna let it spread and pray
that there is a herd immunity and as the
virus started to spread the government
quickly changed its tune so people
contacted me and watched these messages
and from people in Italy in Spain and
said look we pulled our kids out of
school when we heard your video
and you know thank God that we did and
there's still a small amount of people
but I looked at the graph today we're
almost 100 deaths a day here in the UK
two weeks behind Italy in America now
you've gone up to about 200 a day so I
think America's gonna get hit really
hard all of a sudden no tsunamis coming
then I believe that US is at 800 total
right now is that right is that sound
about right
I just checked it I don't know what the
total is but I think it's 200 in a day
there's the thing when it was like 10 20
people say no you know the flu kills way
way more than their what the flu is
constant and we've adapted to it this is
a completely unknown thing that humanity
is never experienced and every three
days it's doubling so you know when
you're kidding you got 2 times 2 is 2 4
to 4 plus 4 is 8 8 plus 8 16 and all of
a sudden you're at like 1,000 2,000
that's what's happening right in front
of our eyes what kind of people have you
been talking to have you been talking to
people in like the healthcare industry
we're talking to scientists researchers
all of the above I'm talking to people a
lockdown in Spain in Italy talking to
people who are working in the health
community and I'm talking to scientists
and I'm talking to doctors
I interviewed a doctor who believes it
was come out of a bio weapons lab in
Wuhan dr. Cottle of Harvard and tomorrow
I am interviewing a doctor who's an
expert on pandemics who explains how it
comes from the animal kingdom so we're
trying to cover absolutely every angle
of this story and my thing was not to
cause panic
it was just give people a heads up
because people started sending me these
messages and I think no more prepared we
are the less damage this thing is gonna
cause sorry who did you say the doctor
was from Harvard that you talked to him
dr. Cottrell co t TR e ll and what was
he saying about everything so in wuhan
there is a level-4 by a weapons lab and
they were experimenting on corona
viruses among other things
and looking at vaccines Wow
so the fact that that was the and it
broke out a whoop and initially is
really spooky but if you look at the
history of pandemics nature has killed
way more people than humans has I mean
the Spanish flu of the previous century
killed more people than died in all of
the world was combined and if you look
for our history I mean we've just gone
through the greatest period of peacetime
talking about no world wars and no
pandemics in the history of the world
ever so it was inevitable that something
like this would start to happen and my
understanding is some of these areas of
nature the jungles and forests that
we've never cut down and gone into
before there are reservoirs of the virus
in animals such as bats right and once
we once being crouched on their turf
they're like alright we're gonna hit
back and this is how nature hits back
[Laughter]